snc lavalin est mêlé à deux grandes
affaires de fraude et corruption
la plus connue c'est celle de la
construction du centre universitaire de
santé mcgill à montréal plus de 22
millions de dollars qui ont été versés
en pots-de-vin la plus grande faute de
connexion
faisant face à ces accusations dont
fraude et complot
l'ancien pdg de snc lavalin a finalement
plaidé coupable début février à une
seule accusation d'abus de confiance
il doit maintenant purger une peine de
20 mois dans la communauté il faut
prendre en compte d'abord la durée des
procédures plus de six ans en plaidant
coupable
pierre duhaime a pour ainsi dire mis fin
à la saga judiciaire entourant le centre
de santé mcgill
par contre les cas de fraude et de
corruption impliquant snc lavalin en
libye sont loin d'être réglés dans cette
affaire près de 50 millions de dollars
auraient été versés en pots de vin aux
proches de l'ancien dictateur kadhafi
une fraude évaluée à 130 millions de
dollars qui a des ramifications
internationales dans le dossier libyen
trois hauts dirigeants c'est la valley
ont dû faire face à la justice en suisse
riadh ben aïssa a été reconnu coupable
de corruption au canada stéphane roy qui
était accusé de fraude et de corruption
vais retenir un arrêt des procédures en
raison de délais déraisonnables ne reste
que sami beddaoui à être jugés pour
corruption
ce qui est particulier avec le dossier
libyen c'est que l'entreprise
snc lavalin est elle même accusée et
doit faire face à la justice
la direction de l'entreprise tentent
d'éviter le procès car une condamnation
empêcherait snc lavalin d'obtenir des
contrats gouvernementaux pendant 10 ans
au canada
mais le directeur des poursuites pénales
du canada a refusé de négocier un accord
de réparation qui aurait permis à
l'entreprise de payer une amende
au lieu d'aller devant les tribunaux le
premier ministre et son entourage se
défendre d'avoir fait pression sur
l'ancien ministre de la justice pour
éviter un procès à snc lavalin et c'est
précisément cet aspect de la sphère qui
a mené à la crise politique qui secoue
actuellement le gouvernement fédéral
ici vincent maisonneuve radio canada
montréal